IN THIS OPENING PERIOD.
AND WE ARE SET BUFFALO ZONE.
AND THE SABRES HAVE HAD PUSHESS
AGAIN THE DEFENSEMEN SENDS IT'S
THE CORNER.
TO THE LINE AND A GOOD STICK TO
KNOCK IT DOWN OFF TO THE RACE.
I LOVE THIS PASS, UNDERNEATH THE
SECOND.
THAT AWAY TO
AND THEN IT'S THE BUMP TO
NET BY BJORKSTRAND.
HE GAVE HIM NET
THERE.
>> Dan: SABRES WITH THE DRAW,
THAT COULD BE -- I DON'T THINK
IT DID.
>> Dan: OPPORTUNITY.
FOLLOW UP THE FIRST GOAL HERE
WITH TWO GOOD VE THE OUTSIDE AND
THEY COULDN'T FIND A HOLE AND A
LANE TOKIHARJU AND DAHLIN UP FR
JOKIHARJU FA
OFFSIDE AS THAT'S TOUCH GET 1,
SENDS IT BEHIND THE NET.
FL
RIGHT IN FRONT, THEYAND WATCH 1
AT THE FRONT OF THE NET, ALL  S
IN THIS HOCKEY GAME.
CURLS UP, DROPS IT
BRENDAN GAUNCE, THE NATIVE DOWN
WAY TO THE OUTSIDIN WITH THE SH
TUCH IN FRONT OF THE NET.
TRIED TO BANG A BONE THERE.
HE JUST WANTS
OKPOSO WORKS HIS WAY TO THE SIDE
OF THE NET.
AND IT'S UP TOP TO
WHAT YOU SAW BEFORE WAS SKINNER
TRYING TO GET THIS PUCK.
THIS ONE TO THE WING.
TRYING TO CUT CALL THAT
WAS MADE ON KYLE OKPOSO.
HERE'SCENTER.
FOLLOWING UP IS LAINE.
TOUCHES IT TO THE FRONT
COLUMBUS.
HE ALMOST MADE IT
PRESSURED.
PUCK COMES FREE WITH NINE
SECONDS.
THE BAT
BECAUSE SOMETIMES YOU DON'T GET
IT BACK.
>> Dan: IT'S INTERESTING HOW THE
GAME'S EVOLOLEED, GETTING IN TH
VORACEK SCORES.